[MUSIC]
It's the magic of 360.
Welcome to the Graduate School
of Business.
We thought it would be nice for you to
see the campus where you would come and
participate in our program.
As we walk here through town square,
you see these buildings to my left and
to my right.
Those are the buildings
where we hold our classes.
That's where you'll be for
two weeks, learning about how
to be innovative marketers.
Let's go visit a classroom.
[MUSIC]
This is one of our typical classrooms,
beautiful and state of the art.
[MUSIC]
So we're coming on the beautiful
Schwab Residential Center.
[MUSIC]
Also see our signature palm trees.
Here we go the Schwab Residential Center.
The GSB is know for having excellent food
in its executive education programs.
So here we are, this is the courtyard
where you'll be meeting your
fellow participants, and
having three meals a day.
Three extremely nutritious,
highly caloric meals.
So part of the program also includes
guest lectures and in the evening.
Different start up entrepreneurs,
sometimes different investors,
sometimes professors in other
departments in the school that present
some interesting research.
Have a meal in addition to a lecture.
The Romans said,
healthy mind, healthy body.
So here in our programs,
we take care of both of your mind,
bviously through our immersive
work in the class rooms.
But also of your body,
with our meals and, of course, our gym.
Hey guys, how is it going?
A beautiful library is just up ahead.
Classrooms are to my left and to my right.
Oops, stay on the path.
They don't like it here
when you step on the grass.
And off we go to the athletic facilities.
[MUSIC]
Let's step inside of the Arriaga Center.
Here's something else
that I think is cool.
A bouldering space and rock climbing.
[MUSIC]
To my left is karate for
those who need to get nervous energy out.
[MUSIC]
It's our 360 video of a day in the life.
Here is co-director Bobo Shih working out.
>> Hey guys.
My goodness.
[MUSIC]
>> And here we are.
Coming back on to the GSB
campus after our workout.
Ready for a day of classes,
intense learning and
a ton of marketing innovation.
[MUSIC]